- Hi, it's Rie.
Today, a friend will be challenging me
to take a popular food and Make it Fancy.
Today's guest is Curly.
- What's up, Rie?
It is I, possibly one
of your favorite people.
I don't know how you
can reinvent the wheel
with Takis and make something
that's so good better,
but if I know anything is for certain,
I know that the sun will come up tomorrow
and I know that Rie will
continue to kill it.
So I'm so excited to see
what you come up with.
- Takis.
I have had Takis before.
A lot of people said don't eat too much
'cause you get acid reflux.
The lime is the key component.
It's very addictive.
(package rustling)
(Rie crunching)
Oh, yeah.
Takis spiciness comes right at you.
It's spicy but it kind of disappears,
so you kind of want to keep eating.
I like the flavor so I kinda want
to keep this flavor combination
'cause spicy and limey is very delicious,
and color is very bright red.
So I think it's gonna be interesting
if we can use this red color.
I want to make this a meal
more than just a snack.
My fingers are red.
I forgot to bring my lipstick
so maybe I can just put on my lips.
As always, I'm excited to Make it Fancy.
(upbeat music)
All right, here's what I got.
Limes, red onion, masa, microgreens.
Shrimp, cilantro, orange, avocado.
There's one more lime.
Lemon, sparkling water, crema, and garlic.
From the pantry I got vegetable oil,
sugar, flour, white vinegar, simple syrup,
salt, baking powder,
and dragon fruit powder.
All right, let's get started.
Make it Fancy.
(dramatic orchestral music)
First step, one and a half cup water,
half cup sugar,
two teaspoon of salt,
four smashed garlic,
20 Takis.
Bring this to a boil and steep
this for about 10 minutes.
I think this is the great
thing for Halloween.
It's like I'm poaching bones and blood.
Maybe next year I'm gonna
just cook this in front
of my house.
It has been simmering
for about 10 minutes.
I'm going to strain over red onion.
Let it pickle at least one hour.
Cut avocado.
The pit, I think I saw
Alex's Instagram story.
You kinda hold and push.
Perfect.
I think I heard a lot of
people get injured hacking
and twisting.
I think this TikTok hack is very useful.
Add in a blender.
Quarter cup of crema,
one tablespoon of lemon juice,
one garlic,
quarter cup of cilantro,
a little bit water first so
it's gonna blend smoothly.
I'm going to blend until vibrant green.
You know what Japanese
people call avocado?
Morino bataa.
It is butter from forest.
All right, crema looks great.
Add in a bowl and we are
moving on to next step.
Two cups of Takis in a food processor.
Put this in a bowl.
I'm adding two tablespoon of ground Takis,
half cup of masa harina,
one tablespoon of dragon fruit
powder just for the color.
Quarter teaspoon of salt.
Mix it up.
Oh, this is beautiful.
Add quarter cup of warm water to start
and I'm going to keep adding as needed.
- [Producer] When do you
think Takis were invented?
- 1962.
- [Producer] 1999.
- Wow!
So it's a recent invention.
- [Producer] Introduced
in America in 2006.
- I came to New York in 2007.
So me and Taki were in
America very similar time.
We are both immigrants.
While dough is coming together,
so I'm going to use my hand.
This is so pretty.
The texture should be like Play-Doh.
It's slightly wet but it's not sticky.
We are going to cover this
and let it sit in room
temperature about one hour.
But we have plenty things to do.
Now it's a little bit firmer and I'm going
to divide into four and make
it like a golf size ball.
Another torture device.
(producer laughing)
Put parchment paper on the bottom.
Another parchment paper and press it.
Beautiful.
I used tortilla press but if
you don't have it at home,
you can roll it up with rolling pin.
Put this in the pan.
Since this tortilla looks so pretty,
I will cook one minute per side.
I don't want to make any
brown or brown color.
- [Producer] Do you remember
the first time you met Curly?
- I just remember he is so
sweet and nice to everyone.
I always wanted to be friend with him.
He brought his grandma for a Tasty shoot.
He was holding her hand and one
of my coworker had a
fake cockroach on a desk.
I think it was close to
Halloween or something.
Curly just like quietly hide it
'cause he didn't want to scare her.
I thought it was so cute.
Okay, I see a little bubble
and I think it's ready.
I want to keep this warm and
I don't want to break it,
so I'm going to put under the blanket.
I always wanted to make this.
My dream came true.
I'm not using oil because
it's a non-stick pan.
This looks cooked.
Put this here, keep it warm.
I'm going to finish making tortillas
and I'm going to move on.
I'm heating up oil to 350.
While oil is heating,
I'm going to make batter.
One cup of flour,
quarter cup of Takis.
This is the powder I made earlier.
Half teaspoon of baking soda,
half teaspoon of salt.
Mix.
When I make this dish I usually use beer,
but since Curly doesn't drink,
I'm using sparkling water.
You don't want to over mix it.
Just like lightly mix.
I have eight shrimps peeled and deveined.
Season shrimp with salt.
Coat with flour.
Dredge in butter.
It kind of look like what's the medicine?
Pepto-Bismol.
I'm going to fry and I don't
want to overcrowd my oil
so I'm going to fry maybe four at a time.
Wow.
It kind of look like a giant Cheetos too.
The sparkling water kinda
gives nice airy texture.
Shrimp cooks very quickly
so I'm just cooking about two minutes.
When the oil bubbles start coming
and shrimp is floating on the surface,
it's ready.
It's cute but if somebody
who is eating this
for the first time,
they couldn't guess this is shrimp.
It's basically a tempura 'cause tempura,
you want to use seltzer water.
I think, yeah, the baking soda
also gives nice fluffy texture too.
All shrimp are fried but we
have some more things to do.
Leftover Takis powder,
add in flaky salt,
toss a little bit, glass.
Using lime, we are making mocktail.
Put the glass upside down
and kind of around the rim.
Oh, it's so cute.
So festive.
I'm gonna add ice each glass.
Donk.
Ice in a shaker.
Two ounces of orange juice.
One ounce lemon juice.
Three ounce of lime juice,
and shake it.
(mocktail rattling)
Ooh, it's icy.
If you are making margarita,
obviously you have to add tequila.
You usually use triple sec,
but triple sec also has alcohol in it
so I used orange juice instead.
I'm topping off with sparkling water
and use lime as a garnish.
All right, drinks are
done and time to move on.
Put tortilla on the plate.
First I'm adding avocado crema,
spread it using spoon's back.
Add shrimp, pickled onion,
and some microgreens.
Now I have some crema in a squeeze bottle.
Top with cilantro.
Since we have some leftover Takis salt,
going to sprinkle and we are done!
(uplifting music)
Shrimp Takis tacos, very fancy.
- I don't know where you
may have used the Takis,
but I'm assuming it's in the tortilla.
- Yes, I made a tortilla with Takis.
Yeah, I also made a
margarita virgin mocktail.
- I just went to a
restaurant and I was like,
"Hi, could I get a mocktail?"
And they were like, "We're out of mock."
And I was "No, um, it's, no, mocktail,"
and she had no idea what I was saying.
Someone has to be like,
"Virgin, make it a virgin."
"Oh yes, that we do."
Cheers, cheers.
- Cheers.
- Oh my God.
This is truly one of the
best tacos I've ever had.
- Oh my God.
- This is so, I'm from LA.
Born and raised in Hollywood.
I'm from LA, hands down it's
one of the best I've ever had.
- Yes!
Takis savory!
- Wow, cheers.
- Cheers.
- Rie?
- Yes.
- How are you this perfect?
(Rie gasping)
Do you think that I could make this?
- Of course, it's easy.
- Our Lord and savior, Rie.
(Rie giggling)
- We have one last thing to do.
- Mm hm.
One, two, three.
- [Both] Make it Fancy.
(both howling)
(cheerful music)